(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- Festivus for the rest of us.
- Festivus (clangs) for the rest
of us.
- I have a lot of problems with
you people
and now you're gonna hear about
it.
- We got a grievance.
- People who drink coffee
through a straw,
I hope you die from the wax
and the plastic that
melts as you suck it up
into your dumb mouth.
- Why do men say they're
pregnant with their wives?
- The lady's doing all the work.
Why are you trying to
take some of the credit?
- Anytime I'm on an airplane
and a brother's staring
at the seat in front
of him and there's no TV on the
seat back,
you leave that brother alone.
- There might not be
anything worse than people
who chew with their mouth open.
- Either close your mouth when
you chew,
or leave your mouth wide open
and don't chew at all
and throw the food into your
throat.
- No soup for them!